with Gary like oh no this is very hate
to make the comparison because they're
completely different but it's very
Connor like when they say something like
oh he actually he believes that that's
not like a gimmick like a lot of guys
are doing
all right Kenny it's interesting Almeida
is like very close to the top of the
heavyweight division already and yet
we're going to lead our show in an hour
with Ian Machado Gary man I mean no
doubt about it people just don't
understand the extent to which this kid
is a mental giant he's just getting
started at 25. I could go on but uh yeah
I mean if he's not a future Champion I
certainly think at some point he's
fighting for the title and uh I feel
pretty good going chips to the center of
the table on that kid even right now
what is popping fam it is Monday May
15th in a lovely sunny Calabasas
California morning what is going on fam
we had a very special episode today
because my boys the two brilliant men
from the John anik and Kenny flooring
podcast available on DraftKings now is
jumping on the show to chat some
fisticuffs with me to my favorite people
I've known these guys for a hot second
I've worked with both gentlemen and uh
they're two of the smartest brightest
men in the game so I'm happy to have
them on the show today breaking down
everything UFC related pfl Francis
ingano news so should be a fun one as
far as tour dates coming up this Friday
I'm at the Ice House shopping friends 8
P.M show it's almost sold out
um it is Eric Griffin Sam Tripoli Jeff
dye we got a whole freaking lineup of
monsters that is this Friday at the ice
house yeah you have air Griffin Jeff
dies Sam Tripoli Grant Cotter it's gonna
be a fun way fun one that's at 8pm at
the new Ice House in Pasadena Pasadena
California uh and that's just the shop
and friends but as far as tour dates
goes I'm back on the road starting June
2nd through the 4th in La Jolla
California basically San Diego right
outside San Diego La Jolla Comedy Store
one of the best venues in all of the
land that's going down June 2nd through
the 4th that's a Friday two shows
Saturday two shows Sunday one show at 10
p.m so that's in La Jolla California at
The Comedy Store and after that your
boys jumping across the pond uh this is
one show in every city in Europe
um it's a theater run so it starts in
Belfast June 15th Glasgow June 17th
Manchester June 18th London June 22nd
Cardiff June 23rd and I'm ending the
Tour in Dublin June 25th can't wait I
will see you guys there let's jump right
into the show
um to my faves like I told you guys you
got John annik Kenny Floyd join me now
enjoy the show this episode the shop
show with Kenny Farm John annik is
brought to you by happy hippo Kratom boy
you guys know I love me some happy hippo
Kratom I use it but for every show and I
reached out to them be part of the show
because I use the product so much helps
me just get stuff done when I need to
however you want to try your Kratom
whether you want to get it in your
freaking powders your gummies I use the
instant shots but happy hippo they're
changing the game you got the new K tips
now you know I love nicotine uh pouches
they're tobacco-free right the nicotine
I use so my friend's a happy hippo say
oh you like to use pouches in your mouth
how about the first ever Kratom pouches
this is the blue Razzle they come in
Wintergreen as well I mess with the blue
Razzle it's the first ever to Market
feel the K Kratom extract infused
pouches man what are they doing the
world's first game changing tobacco
nicotine free Kratom extract pouches
this is a happy hippo exclusive
exclusive it's available right now at
happyhippo.com and you can save 20 off
when you go to happyhippo.com promo code
is thick23 for 20 off that's thick with
three C's try the new K dips the first
to Market ever Kratom pouches ktips
available right now at happyhippo.com I
know you guys like me using all the
nicotine pouches I'm gonna use the
tobacco pouches try the Kratom step your
game up feel Decay the new K dips from
Happy Hippo First Market ever is
available right now they have winter
green they hit the blue Razzle which I
like it's less than one gram of sugar
per pouch all right you don't have to
spit and all that stuff it's not that
it's not like chewing tobacco all right
so it's tobacco-free nicotine free it's
just absolutely pure Kratom heaven in a
pouch k-dips happyhippo.com promo code
thick 23 for 20 off get you some
especially you John coming off uh the
big uh Charlotte card my man wait before
we get into fighting before we get any
fighting my nuggets are playing the
Lakers I would bet hard cold cash I know
you're betting man so are you kidding I
bet hard cold cash it's nuggets for
Celtics in the finals
well the Celtics I feel like have been
the best team for two years no rings as
yet to show for it so I like your uh
your forecast but yeah I mean I think
the nuggets are the team to beat right
now if I look at the final four you know
they'll be favored obviously in this
series against the Lakers and I think
depending on how it goes they'll be
favored against the Celtics but uh yeah
we're hopeful man you know as soon as DC
walked into our fighter meeting and
started banging on the Celtics down 3-2
I knew they were going to win games
we just need Tatum we just need Tatum to
keep dropping 50 plus points
dang that dude he's such a beast such a
beast yeah and it's weird living in LA
and being you know like a die-hard
nuggets fan like I was at this birthday
party yesterday from one of my son's
friends and all the dads are talking all
this trash about the Nuggets I'm like he
gets out of your mind I was like where
was this energy during the regular
season there's such fair weathered fans
for sure well Alexander volkanovsky is a
big Denver Nuggets fan because he
crossed paths with Jamal Murray and he
was befriended by those guys I actually
bought him a Celtics jersey number 55 to
try to push him in that direction
certainly the bulk man is hoping that
it's a nugget Celtics final but no I
mean I don't have to tell you when Jamal
Murray's healthy when the nuggets are
healthy they're a totally different team
and jokic is the best player that I've
seen certainly this year with respect to
Joel embiid I thought you were gonna
lead with me being in Charlotte North
Carolina so I got to see the team
Florian relocation from Venice
California to uh to the east coast and
let us just say the man made a good
decision you love it out there Kenny
it's cool man we we like it we like it
it's been fun man good for you man yeah
that Charlotte crowd was nuts they were
into it for a fight night too was it the
biggest gate for a fight night I think
yeah that's what I heard biggest
domestic audience to 18 712 I believe
for a domestic UFC Fight Night I kind of
felt like UFC Fight Night dealershaw
Cruz in Boston might have been 20 000
plus but I guess I was wrong on that
yeah it was a great crowd and uh I did
say on the broadcast people tend to boo
the wrestling and the grappling almost
instantaneously in the U.S so if I had
any complaint about that crowd it's only
that they just had a little bit of
impatience when it came to the wrestling
the grappling but I just have to say as
a city in terms of the people and a
place that I would probably relocate in
my family if I could right now at
Charlotte North Carolina yeah it was
just uh it blew my mind I mean you know
the kids gotta what I mean what is it a
40-foot swing attached to a goddamn tree
in his backyard what
yeah Kenny you didn't have that in
Venice California my man no I didn't I
didn't yeah how many feet Kenny how many
feet it's pretty damn tall dude so yeah
he's gonna get very injured on this
thing
are there state taxes out there there is
there is not like La I mean not like
Cali but uh it's definitely a lot less
and how's that how's that Homeless
situation is the homeless popping out
there like L.A nah nah nah man I mean I
might be joining you guys too let me
know annik will again we'll get a time
show together man makes the families as
long as you're cool with fish though
right exactly
yeah I thought the the Charlotte card
overall man was stacked for for a fight
night and uh obviously though the
narrative on I think uh Ian Gary stole
the show I think he walked away as the
superstar in the entire card that kid
has Superstar written all over him and
you know you guys know more the so than
anyone when Fighters come in they have
like that arrogance about him and
they're calling their shots and there's
this you know sense of confidence and we
can feel when it's not authentic with
Gary like oh no this is very hate to
make the comparison because they're
completely different but it's very
Connor like when they say something like
oh he actually he believes that that's
not like a gimmick like a lot of guys
are doing
right Kenny it's interesting Almeida is
like very close to the top of the
heavyweight division already and yet
we're going to lead our show in an hour
with Ian Machado Gary man I mean no
doubt about it people just don't
understand the extent to which this kid
is a mental giant he's just getting
started at 25. I could go on but uh yeah
I mean if he's not a future Champion I
certainly think at some point he's
fighting for the title and uh I feel
pretty good going chips to the center of
the table on that kid even right now
okay well what's cool yeah what's cool
is you could see that passion that he
has for the game which I think you
absolutely need to have it's not like oh
he's there to be famous or anything like
he wants to fight he wants to face the
best and he's got the talent man and
every single fight we've seen him in I
think we've seen improvements so he's
clearly training with the right guys
he's traveling around
um and wants to prove himself and he's
doing that each and every fight I like
the progression of his career too like
you know d-rod was not an easy that's an
easy night in the office man d-rod's no
joke and he passed set with fine colors
so you got you got Ian Gary on there you
got a lot of guys that I think are gonna
fight for a title pretty soon here you
know with the main event heavy weights
then he also had Johnny Walker Anthony
Smith
yeah it's a great time for a lot of
these divisions and I hate to cut you
off but the welterweight division is
interesting because I just looked at the
rankings before we came on and Kamara
Usman and kamza chimaya are up there
occupying slots like one and four two
and four so there's gonna be a lot of
movement in the UFC's welterweight
Division and I know Ian Gary's got a lot
of teammates residing in that top 15 but
dude I mean this kid man the appetite
for knowledge like he's going to Brazil
May 21st because he wants to really wrap
himself around how they do Jiu Jitsu
which seemingly is different than
anywhere else in the world you guys both
can obviously speak to that and then
he's going to go to [__] New Zealand
to hang out with Israel a lot of Sonya
you know better [__] get him now Neil
magni and everybody else better get him
now I agree he called out Neil magnney I
was like ooh that is a tough test for
him but I like you know and Neil's my
guy trading with Neil's a Neil hopefully
he's not watching the show but that's a
tough one man you know this Gary kid is
the real deal man I'm all in when I get
all in on guys I am the biggest dick
rider man I'll buy Church you know I'll
be a little cage rat next yelling his
name and [__] yeah it's funny you say
that because I bought his merch
yesterday on Instagram yeah and the
thing is I support the whole roster
right there's this false narrative that
I support only Bilal Mohammed and nobody
else I try to support all the athletes
right you know I mean I think I bought a
cannabis grinder on sugar Shawn's
website you know I try to spread try to
spread out the love you have to man you
have to but yeah I'm all in on this kid
but yeah the whole the whole night I'll
tell you what was interesting too is in
the I know I'm jumping around a little
bit but with the Anthony Smith uh Johnny
Walker fight obviously very tough night
in the office for Anthony Smith
um the and I love Anthony Smith huge fan
Anthony Smith the only reason I want
Johnny Walker to win is because I wanted
Johnny Walker Alex Pierre that's what I
that's my my dream fight at light
heavyweight for whatever reason I'm
weird I think it'd be such a fun fight
but I thought it was so interesting when
Anthony Smith was losing they picked up
on the mic he goes you came for my
family
and I was like oh is this like one of
those like flashbacks when he was
getting robbed at the house you know and
because Johnny Walker was like what he's
like you came from my family so on the
narrative online especially on Twitter
was like is he having like a PTSD type
of situation because Johnny Walker's
like I never came for your family what
are you talking about man
wow yeah you're opening my mind right up
on a Monday morning about being honest
because it did seem out of left field
now if you don't know the narrative
coming in Johnny Walker ended up in
Omaha Nebraska training with one of
Anthony Smith's coaches or former
coaches and that seemed very much like a
mind game like Johnny Walker right it's
sort of a weird backdrop to begin with
right Brazilian guy trains in Ireland
met his wife there and now he's in Omaha
Nebraska Trader but what a lighthouse
coaches you know but so I don't think
there's any family stuff going on and um
hey I mean Anthony Smith is one of my
dear friends I think he's probably a
future color commentator for the UFC if
I could go as far as to say that but
he's great at it too he's really really
good at it yeah again this this is you
know I'm out of the game man I you know
I tell dick jokes for a living I'm just
saying I thought it was very you know
where he's like he came from my family I
was like oh is this like one of those
like is that what he needs to get goat
to get this motor going like is he
traumatized by the Home Invasion there
to it could be completely off and
Anthony Smith like yeah I was thinking
about that incident I remember when I
was watching his flight but a pretty
crazy story that guy just breaking
imagine you know someone at like 4 a.m
just some dude screaming at the top of
their lungs uh who's not supposed to be
in your house and you got your kids
there I mean that's just insane but um
yeah you know for Anthony Smith I it
seemed like he didn't really want to be
there and Johnny Walker seemed like he
was hesitant to go out there and finish
the job it was kind of an odd fight uh
there and you know I think that's always
going to be uh the question mark when
you get a guy who is doing commentating
or he's doing you know the fight
analysis while he's fighting and
obviously I did that uh people are gonna
ask questions like is this what he wants
to do is he halfway in halfway out
um and for Anthony Smith I don't know
the last few fights I don't know if it's
directly related to him doing work TV
work but just looking from the outside
in um and being honest I don't know it
didn't seemed like he wanted to be there
that night I don't know something
definitely seemed to be off and it just
wasn't that flight but because one thing
about Anthony Smith he's a dog man you
know I guess in the regional circuit
like I did I've known about Anthony for
a long time Anthony is a dog through and
through so a lot of fights yeah when I
see that yeah I agree did you have
similar feelings Kenny when you knew you
had a kind of a path so you kind of
you're not one foot you know you're kind
of one foot in one foot out because you
know you're gonna have a career doing
this thing yet you're still competing at
the highest level
I did not I I never really had that um I
knew that like hey when I'm done I'm
gonna be done I had no problem Calling
it Quits and when my body kind of gave
out my back was just kind of repeatedly
giving out on me I'm like all right I'm
done but when I was fighting you know I
I would take time off I would always
take like at least a month off away from
doing TV stuff and and I'd always get my
training in when I was working and
traveling but
um I don't know maybe I wasn't working
as much as some of these guys too so you
look at domway Cruz schedule you know I
just had him on uh calabas fight
campaign he was telling me how he's like
I'm you know I'm I'm not retired man I
have no plans to he's like I'm still
doing the works he's like so not only
you know he worked Charlotte with you uh
John but he was like you know I'm
training six days a week still so I have
to manage the schedule and then I'm also
trying to put in the work for the
broadcast I'm like jeez dude to compete
at that level and the demands that it
takes you guys know better than anybody
it's it's not easy man yeah when Dominic
has a fight he will uh shut it all down
for probably eight to ten weeks and I
think for Anthony Smith there's a lot of
layers to this right it just crossed the
one year anniversary of his mother's
passing and he didn't effectively mourn
that early on I think now he did there
was a dust up with Mark Montoya back in
the day they have since buried the
hatchet they are realigned there's a lot
of traveling when it comes to his
training and then he goes home to the
four daughters just a lot of back and
forth and a lot of asking of himself I
think mentally and emotionally and
physically so uh you know I do believe
that uh sometimes guys just think they
can do it all and uh sometimes you just
don't sort of give enough credit to the
mental and how much it can weigh on you
but um you know I do think the story is
Johnny Walker I know a lot of people are
critical of the performance
sometimes we hear guys talk about like
being focused on getting 15 minutes in
and it's sort of a weird mentality that
they're focused on trying to get those
15 minutes with it against the top five
guy because Johnny walk got to be
careful right like my scorecard had a
1-1 going into the third now that might
be the minority but I actually thought
Anthony Smith was some of those right
hands one round two so I understand
Johnny Walker won this fight and I I did
have him winning this fight you can
argue that he won round two got to be
careful [__] around in there with all
due respect yeah I think for Johnny
Walker too The Narrative you know maybe
a little bit of cardio issue issues
early on the career didn't go exactly as
planned now it's kind of coming to
fruition he had what he thought the
fight in the in the bag which I kind of
agree with him with the leg kicks and
overall damage especially almost
finishing the third so I think he was
just kind of weighing the pros and cons
and then also you know Anthony Smith is
a staple of the the division especially
in the the top five for how long I mean
the guy's a damn monster so I think for
Johnny Rock he's like we got this one
man we've done enough work he I think he
could have got him out of there you saw
that jumping knee that kind of rock
Anthony there's some times there we
could have got him out but uh I'm not
mad at it you know obviously the fans
are I'm sure you know some of the UFC
brass probably want to see him get the
Finish but for his progression and I
agree with him when you're going in
there and you're starching the dude in
the first round or maybe the second
round you're not learning a lot about
your training you're training camp where
you're at mentally so for Johnny Walker
I think it was something he needed for
himself in order to move on because now
he's gonna be ranked probably what was
what was he six so I think he'll
probably get in the top four maybe top
five so that it's like oh it's only
tougher from here man those guys are
tough to get out of there too so when I
see them like oh he's he's maturing it's
a good thing
he's doing the opposite of what John
morant's doing he's maturing he's not
going on IG live with guns and playing
grab ass no and Kenny I'll throw it to
you I mean in our fighter meeting the
word that I kept coming back to with
Johnny Walker was maturity came out of
his mouth so that absolutely dovetails
with what you are saying you know uh and
I'm not even suggesting that in the past
you know we've talked about pyor maybe
playing with his food I I don't think it
was that you know uh and I do think that
Johnny Walker he's not asking for a
title fight right so I do think that
it's valuable experience and um you know
we'll see where Anthony Smith goes from
here look like he took off his gloves
Kenny but I think he'll just fight one
more time might even have a new contract
if I'm not mistaken so uh I think you'll
you'll hear from Lionheart at least one
more time if not too I also think it's
respect from Johnny Walker to Anthony
Smith that's how dangerous Anthony Smith
is he's like nah man I've seen this dude
he was headhunting he was throwing that
overhand right repeatedly Johnny Walker
keeps that head pretty high so uh you
know I think all those points are valid
for sure they're fair and you you know
there's uh maturity when he didn't do
the worm and blowing his shoulder out he
did that weird fish thing where his
coach was like reeling a manwich right I
love fish so I dug it he got a lot of
hate on the internet for it but actually
enjoyed the celebration my favorite
celebration of all time Israel a lot of
Sonny's UFC debut when he pissed on the
side of the auction yeah absolutely
brilliant 100
fantastic
territory uh then with the wicked off
Charlotte after this then when the main
event you know you look at Almeida there
the the guy's the real deal huh I mean
his opening shot seemed a little
desperate and yet you know with uh
biggie boy that he got kind of rejected
with that but eventually he got the the
fight to the mat and it's only a matter
of time beautiful Jiu Jitsu you know I
you know I don't think uh rosenstruke is
uh he's probably a three stripe white
belt down there but still he you know he
without me he was smart man he's smart
with it set it up another finish I'm I'm
not fully sold on him like I mean Gary
yet I'd like to see how he does in the
Striking Department against some you
know some guys when he can't get that
takedown before I you know say he's
gonna beat Jon Jones you know and stuff
like that but the guy's a Savage that's
for sure
First Team all body as well
yeah Kenny I mean there aren't a lot of
points of comparison when it comes to
offensive Jiu Jitsu and the the history
of heavyweights in mixed martial arts
and we're not even talking about
Fabricio over Doom or Frank Mir some of
these elite elite guys no Guerra right
this dude is a little bit of a different
breed he can strike two he hasn't even
had to show anybody that
um yeah maybe a little bit undersized uh
but man he knows how to get to where he
wants to get to and get guys out of
there I I'm not so sure that uh he's not
gonna expedite this process here what
did he weigh in out before you go okay
what are you weighing at
he was light now is he going to stick
with heavyweight or is he going to go
back and forth I mean the dude is a
physical specimen man he could have been
a professional box I mean heavyweight
heavyweight it's like as deep as like a
splash pool right so I think I'm just
kidding no no good point he's right
there already he's already right there
in the top you know eight probably so
Rosen strike looked like a refrigerator
though he was big I mean it was wide I
mean
yeah put on some weight like did they
say 20 pounds
yeah so it's an interesting narrative
because if you do go back and look at
his UFC debut against Junior baby Albini
remember the guy who wore the diapers
uh he weighed 241 and a half and he
looked thin right like his face was
thinner than mine back then right so now
265 cutting down to the Limit most of
that is muscle in this match I'm not
sure that's particularly useful but no I
mean I don't know he looks pretty strong
to me but yeah 25 pounds since the uh
since the debut wow yeah age too you
know sometimes the the weight just comes
man you know it's like yeah like Almeida
tried to hit a double leg at one point
like literally bounced off of the dude
just like bounced back he's like all
right let me reset uh but then once he
once he got him on the ground man he was
just dominant excellent control moved
into the mount seamlessly and uh yeah
the fight was was over pretty much
shortly after that so he's looking good
man he really is and I think you know to
Brendan's point I'd like to see him get
a little more comfortable on the feet
and obviously you don't want to trade
with someone like Rosen strike for too
long but um you know he maybe a little
panicky out there and again that's going
to come from experience right he hasn't
been in the UFC for a whole for for a
long time so but I think with fights uh
with more fights with more octagon time
we're going to see that Comfort level
and maybe see more of a strike and kind
of come out and his overall mixed
martial arts game but uh no question the
dude's got some serious potential but
also that's the first Main Event too his
first Main Event so that could have been
a little bit of panic there it's
rosenstruke who's uh artist I'm just
saying when I when I look at the lay of
the Land There you look at Sergey
pavlovich like that takedown ain't gonna
get it done there Bubba that that's not
going to do it now I don't know how his
chain wrestling how single leg is right
and heavyweight that's super important
so yeah we'll see but you know the kid
has a ton of potential ton of potential
well you put forth a performance like
that and I do hear a lot of people
saying oh Sergey pavovich is going to
knock his head off and yeah that
sometimes happens I think in the fight
game is you you see this guy emerge and
it's like well wait a second look what
Sergey pavlovich did to Curtis blades
who to me is the one of the greatest
fighters in UFC history to have never
fought for a title in any division but
looking like jairiel to Almeida against
Curtis blade like he's gonna approach
this career I would think Almeida is as
a specialist trying to take everybody
down chain them together uh like
desperately trying to get this to a
grappling situation because he can put
people away you know I remember I'm a
broken record when it comes to this but
offensive Jiu Jitsu is just a lost star
like Daniel Cormier went to kenflo back
in the day at Fox like tell me how to
like have a real good signature rear
naked choke that I can always execute in
the Octagon among other things that he
went to Kenny about but like dude it's
like there's so many of these guys right
even guys who are holding the highest
regardless Muhammad like they get you
down all day they don't necessarily have
a signature choke or the means by which
to get to a mount or a back to to put
you the [__] away yeah my only kind of
Hiccup there without meter it's like you
know he goes you know you look at these
guys that are so successful just being
Specialists from grappling in his list
he you know he listed khabib obviously
and some some other huge names those
guys have a background extensive
background and straight up wrestling
there's not a lot of pure Jitsu guys
that get to the top
if that makes sense you you that's fair
you know as far as like straight Jiu
Jitsu where you don't have an extensive
wrestling background to get the guys to
the mat you know there's a difference
between a guy like khabib or a guy like
Ben Astron or DC who they're gonna get
you to the mat whether you liked it or
not you know Jon Jones if he wants to
those guys it's just a different level
that they're coming from opposed to
Almeda with that pure Jujitsu with a lot
of ghee the trip stuff like that it's
tough to pull off at a high level in MMA
Kenny do you hate that or yeah no I
think I think the focus is different
right first of all obviously Jiu Jitsu
guys aren't necessarily known for
um crisp and efficient takedowns um and
a lot of guys you know they'll look for
ways
um to kind of you know maybe sweep or
get on top and they I think
transitioning from the sport of Jiu
Jitsu is so different for these guys
they haven't come from that aspect of
this is a fight I'm going to use my
strikes to set up submissions I think I
think you're right though when you're
talking about guys who can finish from
that top position there's there's Damian
Maya
um and and he he could do that because
he worked heavily on his wrestling but
as far as other Jitsu guys that are just
so dominant you have uh Oliveira but
I mean maybe that's it and there's you
know some high-level Jiu Jitsu guys
walking around in the UFC but you know
Ryan Hall is great but he he'll do it
mostly off of his back and all you know
transitions
um I I think we'll see that from him
when he does get on top but
um as far as guys who have shown it time
and time again Damien Maya and Charles
Oliveira kind of the only guys that come
to mind so I agree with John that it is
a dying art and um what they need to do
is start to get together and work on
their wrestling uh get together with the
wrestlers and learn what they're doing
and wrestlers need to get together with
the Jutsu guys and and uh figure out
what's going on in the ground but um
we're just not seeing that if I'm I'll
meet I'm bunking up with Bo nickel I'm
moving to Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and
bunking up with Bo nickel that's what
I'm gonna do for sure
I guess I just feel like tarzenia Rosen
strike however green and white he is in
the Jiu Jitsu realm spends nine weeks
trying to avoid this very fate of being
finished by the six to one favorite in
round one and sure as [__] jayield and
Almeida goes out and finishes him in
round one and I do think in some
respects it is easier said than done so
I'm curious right uh and I also think
too you know we're now five fights deep
Five Fighter meetings deep with this guy
we see the maturity uh and it really I
think through interpretation can
translate in that setting you realize
how thoughtful he is so yeah I mean I'm
a promoter but I'm very excited yeah I'm
excited regardless yeah I think this
guy's the limit for him to a few small
changes just that heavyweight division
those top dogs a lot of a lot of
wrestling up there that he has to get by
especially with Pavlich you know and
Curtis blades uh yeah you know him him
verse um inverse some some of the other
guys uh Sarah gone would be interesting
you know stuff like that but um you know
moving on
obviously super dear to you guys uh our
boy blue Muhammad who I can't you know
one of the greatest guys walking this
Earth got the job done against Gilbert
Burns you know the the thing that
bothers me about the narrative is oh
Gilbert was hurt it's like it well blow
has nothing to do with that so I think
he's the most underappreciated guy we
have in the UFC and even you know I
think even if he went in there and got a
30 second knockout he still wouldn't
have got his credit you know him and Al
Jermaine Sterling are the most
disrespected guys in the UFC which I
don't understand because the two of the
greatest guys you'll ever meet you know
they're just solid people so with balil
it's like you know I don't think
regardless how that fight went he was
gonna get the title shot you know Dana's
pretty stuck on uh Kobe and Leon so for
Muhammad you think he gets probably one
more in before he actually gets that
title shot or he's just gonna he's gonna
chill he's gonna be the alternate for
that fight no I don't know if he'll be
the backup but uh he certainly will
fight for the title next there will be
no title Eliminator and uh obviously
this is close to me and Kenny if you
don't know he has a show on our Anakin
Florian podcast YouTube channel but
before I spin it over to kenflo he knew
that he was not going to be offered a
title Eliminator unless it was in a
circumstance like this on short notice
right it seemed like maybe the
foundation was going to be late for him
to fight rachmanov and only if he beat
him would he get a fight like a Gilbert
Burnside so
he had to take the Gilbert Burns fight
he took it he went a little bit too full
throttle injured his ankle thought
through all of that and uh just as
mentally forged as Gilbert Burns or
anybody else right I mean we got mad
love for dorino of course but uh yeah I
mean Bilal knew that he had to take this
fight to to set up a title fight and
yeah he'll sit for 18 months if he has
to good for him yeah you know below is
one of those guys you know I've talked
about this on the podcast and maybe I
could relate to a little bit where guys
are like you know there's nothing that
stands out on this guy there's nothing
that Wows you but man he knows how to
put it all together
um and and what's really interesting
about Bilal he's also kind of a
chameleon in that he can beat you in a
lot of different ways
um you know he may not be that crazy
finisher but uh he knows how to win
rounds and he can do it in a variety of
ways and I think that's what makes him
such a tough out for a lot of people
Gilbert Burns had a lot of momentum
heading his way but I think when they
got inside the Octagon even I was a
little surprised at how much bigger
Bilal looked and considering all the
outside circumstances that ball had to
deal with you know the injured ankle
taking the fight on short notice coming
off from Ramadan all those things and
still seeing him perform that way like
he did a five round camp for months
um was pretty mind-bending man it was
really really in impressive and
obviously you know prove that he's the
next guy to get the shot and um
absolutely deserved it
agree 100 I think too with Muhammad it's
to me he checks all boxes right we both
I mean obviously John and Ken you guys
are interviewing Fighters all the time
you're watching all the fights you know
I have a lot of Fighters come through
here with Muhammad it's like well this
guy checks every box man he can he's
well spoken educated guy you know his
immigrant mentality his family that
starred in Chicago and owned a business
and just the way he came up he to me
checks all boxes I guess if um you know
let's say I was a promoter I guess the
one kind of Hiccup would be he's not
known as a finisher obviously the Sean
Brady was a big finish for him but
outside that that'd be really be the
only kind of uh [__] yeah he doesn't
talk [__] that's the other thing right
and he shouldn't because that's not his
style that's not what he does he's being
authentic to himself but I think that's
the other thing you know he's not out
there you know being flashy and and
doing a bunch of interviews outside of
camps you know he's doing all of his
work behind closed doors I think and I
think that's
uh could be a hindrance to him at times
as well uh you know he's he's not out uh
acting the fool and and um you know for
better or worse and I think uh that that
hurts him a little bit maybe marketing
wise yeah I think Dominic Cruz said it
best you know I said how do you feel
with you know obviously the UFC's merged
with the under the same banners WWE and
guys that do talk trash and do all these
flashy things might you know get get to
the title shot faster get more Fame
faster more Instagram followers faster
and you know Dominic said it great he
goes you know if that's what the
company's asking and you can see that
guys do that you know maybe they don't
have to go through the same kind of uh
as many fights to get a title shot the
road's different he's like so you can do
that if you want and you know it's going
to help you out and if you choose not to
that's fine but you're just gonna have a
tougher Road and for Muhammad she says a
tougher Road you look at certain guys
they just have a different Road man so
yeah you can do it and maybe you might
you know get a shot faster but for
Mohammed he's like no I'm just gonna be
true to myself but boy it's gonna be a
tough road but when you do get to that
title shot there's not a person on this
Earth who can argue that Muhammad didn't
earn every single right right fight for
a title but you you're right I mean you
did not bury the lead the chief knock on
him is that he hasn't put a ton of
people away right and the only other
thing I really see is that he doesn't
necessarily have
the the fan support of certain people
right like obviously him and Al Jermaine
Sterling got a pretty good and new work
and there's a big Brazilian population
in New Jersey so perhaps that cloud of
things a little bit right but correct me
if I'm wrong fellas like it's good when
the fan base really likes you right and
that is reflected in the internal
metrics right like for all of the people
who think sahuto is just so
cringe-worthy you know kids got a fan
base you know and bilal's got a fan base
too don't get me wrong you know but if
allows walking out in Newark the like
Gilbert Burns is a fan favorite like you
don't think that helps him with Hunter
and Dana like I think it really does
agree but also you you know for a lot of
times you either want the fan base to
love you or hate you when they're in the
middle it's tough right you know you
look at Kobe Covington which I'm sure he
has a good size fan base who actually
love them yeah there's a lot more people
that hate him either way it's a Floyd
Mayweather effect as long as they're
tuning in that's all you care about yeah
right no I think that's true you know I
think Kenny needs more haters right
you don't want that Kenny trust me man
it's heavy lies the crown dude I got my
fear of share and it's exhausting yeah
it is exhausting
but you know I mean I think I think a
lot of us extract opinions on both sides
and uh you just kind of take it for what
it is you know
but you look at that welterweight
division obviously Leon Edwards and
Colby Compton are fighting but you know
Hamza and Kamar Usman
I mean it sounds like it's pretty much
done I don't know if you guys have any
side info on that but sounds like it's
pretty much done someone signed a
contract and once I he he put that
little smirky face on Twitter I'm like
oh that's as good as gold this fight's
happening John is is the Colby Leon
Edwards set in stone I don't know if
Leon doesn't have a date right I think
the only thing that could get in the way
of that is if for some reason and I do
not believe this to be true that Colby
Covington somehow wouldn't be ready by
say October right I think Leon has made
it publicly clear that he wants Abu
Dhabi and I will say if ever there were
a market in which Bilal Muhammad can
help you pay-per-view and otherwise it
is Abu Dhabi so maybe there would be an
inside Lane there for Bilal if somehow
there was a circumstance where Colby
wanted to maybe be paid to sit aside
right but no it's going to be Colby
Covington and Leon but Dana White has
publicly said maybe on Jim Rome's show
that he didn't love a catch weight
between Hamza shimayev and Kamara Usman
and I understand why because it does
make things a little bit cloudy right is
Hamza going to be a welterweight
Contender now all of a sudden we were
told he was leaving welterweight for
good he's still number four in the world
right so I don't know I don't need the
water to be any murkier there are plenty
of guys worthy of a championship
opportunity already at 70 but yes that's
a huge fight and if it's like a
middleweight Eliminator then great it
has to be a middleweight those catch
weights do nothing it just holds up the
divisions like you said it gets murky
but the balls in Kamara Usman to go I'll
fight hamzat at middleweight yeah 170
it's a tough task man I mean again I'm a
dick right I'm all in on harms I think
that scares the [__] out of me super
hero just a complete monster right so at
85 though dude who beat Tom's out at 85.
then Kamara Usman that's what kind of
champion he is he goes no I'll fight him
like yeah but humps at 70 he's a
nightmare man he doesn't want to cut the
weight he goes oh no I'll find him at 85
it's like what so much respect for
credit bad ass I couldn't think of a
worse matchup for him it's a tough night
in the office man because homicide can't
he can't it fights man that's how scary
this dude is
there really aren't that many fights
that you can give Hamza Chima if it has
to be a top guy I mean for me I would
argue the dream matchup is Robert
Whitaker and comes out you might have
and perhaps that ship has sailed at
least for now Izzy obviously would give
tremendous issues to hamzajimaya but uh
yeah man I'm just really getting
impatient I want to see Hamza in a
championship setting
Dana said something about uh homs. has
had opportunities and it's been on him
that he's not taking some of these
fights is that is that accurate what
what's going on on that so when we were
in Abu Dhabi Andreas Michael his head
coach essentially came out and this is a
couple of years ago now I mean my
brain's a little bit cloudy as to the
dates but in 2021 this guy was on a
definite welterweight
sure and so I think that's probably what
Dana is referencing that there have been
opportunities for this guy right he was
Thrice booked against Leon Edwards I
mean it's not all that long ago he's
still ranked at 70. his last fight right
wasn't all that long ago and I believe
it was contracted for 70 even though he
weighed more than that you know so but I
don't know I mean let's go already right
it's like he's one of the best in the
world it's just weird to just be losing
big chunks of your pride because I
thought they're gonna do uh Camaro Paulo
Costa I'm sorry Hamza Apollo cost at 85.
I thought that was pretty much done yeah
yeah yeah that's what I heard and then
now that's what I thought yeah I just
want to see him fight I'm with you annik
there's a few guys like I can't wait to
see Ox beer at uh light heavyweight I
think oh my that dude you look at the
matchups my God it's so exciting I can't
wait for him at 205. yeah Savage I am
I'm I think I'm most excited perhaps a
recency biased to just see what happens
with Ian Gary because uh man it's like
he's not even cocky right you talk about
being misunderstood like the kid's not
even cocky he's really just competent
correct right yeah uh and it's uncanny I
mean the depth to this kid right like
I'm stirring the show up shop show back
to Ian Gary right like I'm just I'm
blown away by this kid I was a [__]
idiot when I was 27. look at this kid at
25 years old oh I know saying to me but
there's nothing especially when with
what we do to me there's nothing better
in professional sports name any major
sports League there's nothing better
than mixed martial arts especially in
the UFC when you have a young kid and
his you see him go through all these
levels all these tests there's nothing
when Conor was coming up what a ride man
so I when I see that Ian gear I'm like
oh please give us that special moment
it's so fun dude it's nothing's better
and we talk a lot about Izzy's frame at
85 when I'm handicapping a fight between
Robert Whittaker and Israel a lot of
Sonya I begin the handicap with the size
right and Whitaker may get him if they
meet a third time but man better begin
your handicap with the size and Ian
Gary's frame at welterweight my goodness
man my goodness yeah I'm I'm complete
I'm all in I'm absolutely all in uh for
the next um kind of big pay-per-view
not my favorite pay-per-view right was
at UC 289 in uh in Canada usually they
stacked the Canada card for whatever
reason this one you know obviously I'm a
degenerate I'll pay it could cost 300 I
paid for them but um you know it's not
gonna knock your socks off it is what it
is but in the co-main event that's the
you know that is the the Marquis matchup
on this with Charles Oliveira uh yeah
Houston you look at they're used is kind
of one of those guys who did it the hard
way you know the I think did it the
right way but also did it the hard way
where doesn't talk trash chalks
everything up to Jesus Christ right and
just gets these wins and then here he is
in the title Eliminator with Charles
Oliveira I cannot wait for that fight
yeah Camp flow would pay 99.99 just for
that fight oh it was just the one fight
I would pay for it yeah
I love that fight and I think a lot of
people might be sleeping on Darius in
that one I I think darjeosh has improved
a ton he blew me away with his wrestling
against gamron batao uh gamron I did not
expect that level of wrestling he was
shutting that down repeatedly if it did
go to the ground he was getting back to
his feet
um he has improved his striking he's
gone from being a big Power puncher and
being Reckless to being a big Power
puncher and being way more defensively
sound uh and I think that's an extremely
interesting fight and one that Darius uh
could definitely pull off for Oliveira
he's you know he needs this one in some
ways you know um he obviously wants to
get back to the top uh he has so many
offensive weapons I think defensively he
does have some vulnerabilities and I'm
curious to see if Darius can poke in
prod and and find uh find a way to take
him out yeah I have Darius winning that
fight I picked Darius yeah he's good
dude yeah
yeah I love Charles Oliveira I feel like
my entire sort of UFC career has been
happened while his has and I just can't
get back to the main event against Max
Holloway and Saskatoon where everybody's
questioning is hard to see him then rise
and change his life and have Financial
Freedom but yeah man Benny daru should
uh you know hope he doesn't take issue
with us perpetually calling him [__]
Benny dayush you know but yeah I mean at
this point it's like you win this fight
you need to sit down for however long
and fight for the championship for your
fan base right wow but Neil Darius for
your fan base like at some point you
just need to reward them with the title
fight and candidly like I'm forever
linked to Leon Edwards so if he ends up
fighting Bilal it's like my heart's not
really necessarily invented but for
Bilal Muhammad's haters like you already
[__] lost because he got to the title
fight so you lost it doesn't even matter
what happens in the fight and Bilal
would roll his eyes if he heard me say
that doesn't even matter if Leon beats
him right doesn't even [__] matter
Muhammad hater you already lost yep yeah
boss sure yeah I know how you can hate
on the guy Kenny the next question is
probably more in your direction because
you're involved with pfl you're the head
commentator at pfl
Francis ingano I assume announces is it
did he say he's going to announce this
week all signs are pointing that he's
going to sign with you guys it's it's
very possible I I don't have the inside
track on that I do know okay I know I'm
sorry I'm sorry I can't break news right
now uh but I I know that there is some
announcement
um planned soon so I don't know exactly
when it's coming but I I was literally
I've been asked this for the last couple
days is this Francis is Francis going to
come I don't know for sure but I I
figured we were in the running uh one of
the leading candidates I think it would
be huge for them uh obviously bringing
Francis over uh would be massive so
let's see if we can pull it off man you
in the the noon of on Francis is you
know people are upset the way the fan
base and you know analysts and YouTubers
are critiquing the way he's dealt with
this free agency and leaving the UFC
and I it's not even it's not even a
Francis it's not a personal attack on
Francis I just feel like
you know you look at Nate leaves he gets
a fight announcement pretty soon
fighting Jake so it's just like this
long drawn out thing it's like out of
sight out of mind I think that's where
the criticism comes from and then you
also were hoping for a big fight
announcement because I thought
no knock on pfl Kenny you know I love
you but yeah also it's like I thought
the only reason to leave the UFC you
guys know I'm Die Hard UFC UFC's in my
blood man I absolutely love the UFC but
for him to leave the biggest
organization in the world with the best
marketing machine in the world to leave
the only reason you would leave is that
that golden egg of a Deontay Wilder
Anthony Joshua Fury fight is gonna
happen and we haven't seen that so to me
it's almost If You're Gonna Leave the
UFC it has to be the only way to kind of
improve your status would be getting
that major boxing fight it doesn't sound
like that's gonna happen so to leave the
UFC to go to another MMA organization it
just doesn't sit right with me it just
doesn't care yeah because my argument
before you answer Kenny if I'm his
manager I'd go who are you going to
fight in pfl
right well I mean I I'd say this
obviously you have Jon Jones there right
but after Jon Jones who is he going to
fight you know both divisions
um you know both the heavyweight
divisions across the board aren't the
strongest right now um but I think one
thing you're probably forgetting uh
about is that you know for Francis I
think a lot of it has to do with respect
and there are a lot of um you know it is
complicated with with Francis you know
it's like oh he wants to he's coming off
a knee injury uh you know he wants this
boxing fight but I think the other thing
that people are kind of forgetting about
is that you know I think he has a
history with the UFC where he has butted
heads his management the UFC and I think
it uh at this point is kind of uh about
respect a little bit
um and maybe he's being stubborn right
because obviously you know you have the
UFC which is the biggest mixed martial
arts organization in the world
um and you you as a fighter you want to
prove yourself against the best in the
world
um but for Francis I don't know you know
he's he's a guy that kind of marches to
the beat of his own drum and uh he does
things differently clearly and um I
don't know I maybe the UFC dropped the
ball on that one I I don't know but
um but we'll we'll see what happens man
uh you are right about the respect
though Kenny and it's not just respect
for himself that he's fighting for and
some people have suggested this is sort
of a weird hill on which to die as he's
looking for Clauses that maybe will in
the future help affect things as far as
respect for Fighters right I mean it's
hugely problematic as an MMA fan to
think that 25 years from now the number
10 lightweight in the world is not going
to be making a million bucks to show you
know but it kind of is what it is right
and it's very hard to affect change when
it comes to collective bargaining
agreements and fighter pay and things
like that and Brendan and I have over
the years gotten into a lot of debates
on fighter pay you know
um but I do think part of the issue has
been he's tried to fight for these
things and promotionally it becomes a
little bit difficult you know to sort of
uh accept these type of Demands but yes
I mean I do hope that he realizes that
that big payday and hopefully his bank
account is is pretty fat to begin with
but uh I do think that there's always
UFC heavyweight contenders that emerge
in the UFC but I'm not sure I'm not so
sure B that that ship hasn't sailed I
agree I agree I think he could come back
to the UFC I think it was Francis too if
you're going to make a change you know
that'd be like a a stud quarterback in
the NFL going to again it's not it's not
a knock on pfl Kenny I know you know I
respect that yeah sure I'm just saying
that this is very evident here where
it's like let's say Lamar Jackson want
to make a change for quarterbacks in the
NFL and then goes the Canadian football
league and is demanding these changes
okay right you know it's like okay you
know you gotta be in the biggest
promotion in the world in order to make
a change because if the UFC is not
making a change who gives a [__] yeah
it's a double-edged sword right because
you know you also have to battle the
biggest machine in the world as well so
it's it's it's tough I I agree with you
on some of those things but it also is
it is extremely difficult to affect
change because they're the UFC I mean it
they're they're the kleenex of of uh
correct of tissue right so it's like
um they are the machine they are the
biggest name it's why Dana is so we all
know you know in many ways he's known
then more known than the majority of the
fighters he walked in in Charlotte and
it was like uh
well I don't know it was like the
Beatles walking it's like Donald Trump
more than any fighter I mean Jamal Hill
no one really knew who he was
um you know Al Jermaine Sterling no one
was he came in and everyone looked and
everyone was trying to get to him and
everyone was trying to get out of their
seats to get to him
um this is by Design you know um and
Dana of course is a very charismatic
personality probably deserves a lot of
that but
um I think you have this guy who's
running the organization similar to
Vince McMahon who is you know one of the
biggest if not the biggest name in the
organization more than the fighters is
that right or wrong I don't know but I
think that it's it's it's interesting
that that's the case No On Any Given
card the three most famous guys in the
building are not inside that octagon
it's it's Joe Rogan
Dana White and John annik and none of
these guys you know these guys are
getting punched in the face oh man and
then the most famous guys in the arena
they're also the three smartest guys in
the area
correct
but it is sort of a tricky thing and it
even extends to broadcasting right right
Brendan [__] Brian
like it even extends to the broadcasting
world and not to go into too much detail
but like ESPN right like the NFL doesn't
tell ESPN and ABC who calls the fights
the UFC the UFC tells ESPN who's calling
the flight yeah right UFC controls the
live production it even extends to uh to
TV love that ESPN's pretty big yeah yeah
hey I mean
hey I mean that could be keeping me
employ right I mean who knows ESPN could
want somebody else calling the fights
right I'm just saying though like even
it the uniqueness of mixed martial arts
it extends to the television world as
well that's all no I agree and I I think
there's I have like I have how do I say
I have like anxiety with the the fights
I want to see you know I talked about
Alex Pierre at 205 uh homs out at 85
fighting you know for a big fight there
uh title Eliminator fight hopefully then
also the other one you know I'm a
hardcore dick writer when it comes to
Conor McGregor as well with Connor you
want the Conor and you want the you know
what the Michael Chandler fight to
happen it's depending how you know the
ultimate fighter goes
um you're talking to two tough alumni
here and with me and Kenny so I hope the
ultimate fighter comes back and kind of
gets that momentum it's been a disaster
for hot seconds in season 10 I think
which is the biggest season of all time
credit to I'd say I get credit there but
probably Kimbo Slice right but with
Ultimate Fighter they're they're headed
in the right direction with Connor and
Michael Chandler I just think depend
Conor and the usata testing if we don't
get that fight fairly soon after the
finale
it's tough man so like I said I have
anxiety because I I want to date on
Conor give me something cement in 2023
that he's gonna fight
no I couldn't agree with you more and it
was sort of okay in February yes when we
heard about September but now it's May
and we want to hear about a fight and uh
maybe I can break some news we're
blowing it out for The Ultimate Fighter
I'm flying to Bristol for the first time
in years in two days to film this
Ultimate Fighter launch party love it
we're blowing it out I think we might
even interview Eddie Alvarez The
Underground King which is going to get
me very Starstruck because I haven't
talked to in years but no I think anyone
who's a fan of The Ultimate Fighter is
really going to enjoy everything that
comes with this season it being on
linear TV but there's a huge bot it's
like we need a date bro like I I don't
know I think you laid it out perfectly I
have nothing to have yeah I need a date
I need something to know Connor I need
something even if they're like yeah man
it's gonna be March 2026 I'm like so you
tell me there's a chance right right you
know like give me something because with
you saw it on the test I'm like is this
actually gonna happen
I've said repeatedly that uh the the
competition Conor's looking for is not
anywhere but the competition that could
happen in the Octagon so I'm cautiously
optimistic that he fights fourth quarter
but uh I'm getting impatient you know
June 1st is two weeks away
dang it is isn't it we're going to this
summer summer time man that's right I
think you should buy more fish for the
summer
dude I'm gonna go broke by these damn
this whole house is just gonna be a fish
tank I don't even want to know the
annual allowance right oh dude don't get
me started don't do not get me started
this just popped in my mind can you when
we're talking about guys fighting the
UFC then also doing analyst work I'll
never forget when I was working with you
at Fox we're doing some show you know
whatever the the fox UFC show was there
yeah and we're waiting for valet and I'm
I'm the biggest Porsche fan you ever met
me and Kenny love Porsches that's our
thing and we're waiting you know at the
time I forget I had just an okay car
like the basic 911 you know I was trying
to get my bearings underneath me and I
put all my money into a used 911 which
is like a huge goal for me installing
for my car and this BR and it just they
just came out I don't know how many
years ago it just came out it was a
Carrera GTS Target
Porsche which was like my whole Holy
Grail at the time and pulls up I look at
I go Kenny look at that a brand new
Target dude who do you think that is and
Kenny's like what I look at the [__]
car dude and he goes that's mine
I I I dude I went what he goes that's
fine mail it
wow hey that's wow man all right have a
good day and then here come by busted
911 behind him that's mine I think it
was the first one in L.A you know but
but uh dude yeah so it was you didn't
really see him at the time uh yeah but
here's the thing I think about that once
a week but by the way once a week that
goes through my mind Brendan has
literally had the like like the unicorns
of cars like he's since then he's had a
GT3 RS the GT2 RS oh freaking he's got a
Rari I mean he's got I mean how many
Ferraris do you have at this point this
dude's killing and It Started With You
Kenny once I thought I'm like sorry oh I
need to step my game up dude I will
never forget to shoot I went out to
shoot food truck Diaries and he has some
car that is painted the most beautiful
dark green you've ever seen in your life
so yeah
that's the GT2 Kenny I got it in green
now yeah I love it I think about that
once a week once a week
story and it is cold with 100 veracity
there's no embellishment yeah but all
those cars are investments you can make
more off of those things now you just
have to be able to get one and if once
you get one you'll probably sell it for
more than what I'll tell you right now
it's a better investment than fish I'm
not getting a lot of return exactly
exactly it's a complete nightmare uh
before you get out of here fellas you
know I was talking to my boy Tom you
guys know who who books my show and he
told me a while ago that you guys moved
over to DraftKings now so the the
podcast clear for me and we don't have
to hear this what do you guys want to do
but just from a business aspect so now
the the is the show is is it kind of
like similar to Rogan's Spotify deal
where it's only available on DraftKings
so DraftKings started their own network
so the DraftKings YouTube channel and
the DraftKings Network are where our
full video full-length video episodes
now reside clips of our show are still
on the regular Anakin flooring podcast
YouTube channel nothing changes on the
audio side you know
um but really this just allows us to
align with I think what is a perfect
partner for our show based upon the
content and allows me to pay our staff
right audio engineer and a producer and
a handicapper the coach Ray Longo you
know Ken flow is [__] expensive so
we're very happy to have this deal and
uh I get it you know we uh we sort of at
times have referred to our show as The
Little Engine That Could because we have
focused for eight years on content and
uh you know nice to finally uh you know
have a deal that uh allows us to extend
reach a different audience and go twice
a week which was not the reality for the
first seven and a half years of the show
and uh as I said to pay kenflo to get
his wife up I mean The Little Engine
That Could what are you guys talking
about you guys wearing the Staples in
the freaking sport you know it's not
like two guys we've never heard of it's
two brilliant guys in the space Hall of
Famers talking about fighting man I
listen to show all the time that's why
when I heard the DraftKings deal I was
like oh it's gonna be off Apple now but
then you know this morning I listened to
it no no issues yeah yeah nothing
changed yeah yeah and uh no we're
excited I I went to can flow in 2015 and
uh I'm very thankful that I did you know
we were both on the west coast I was in
Vegas and he was in LA when we started
the show and uh now we're both back East
but uh I might move to Charlotte North
Carolina I'm not even messing around and
then we'd be in studio together so [__]
I might too man I'm looking for it let's
go a little [__] hole so I might have to
go yeah I might get out there man I
might get out there dudes
um with Ray Longo that whole team
crushing it man I had when it in that's
one of the best parts about this gig is
I meet so many people and some people
you Vibe with some you know they're
great but you don't Vibe with them but
that Mike perola the steamroller yeah we
had them on before he fought uh a few
times and we've text back and forth I
just love that kid man I absolutely
[__] love that kid I want the world
for him you see him fight he's he's
coming on the show he has his shirt off
he's a redhead yeah Matt what'd I say
my I said Mike my bad Matt yeah yeah
absolutely he's the man dude yeah that
whole team family that whole team dude I
don't know if you know that verbola's
wife recently gave her father one of her
kidneys I mean they're incredible what
yeah dude this girl
um I think her name's maybe Billie Jean
I shouldn't even have tried it but she's
yeah she's I think 30 some you know
early 30s young girl his wife they just
got married and uh yeah she just gave
one of her kidneys to her dad but yeah
we know the whole family Sal the
bulldozer for Ebola his father yeah
great group and nice to see them realize
some uh some success because uh you know
he's always been a really good fighter
painted with a brush of a guy who just
goes in their balls to the wall but uh
he's top 15 now yeah I told him that
Drew Dober fight it was Monday he's
fighting on that Saturday I go Matt I
love you dude you gotta fight smart Drew
Dober I've known for a hot second we
came up with a regional circuit together
that's not a guy you just want to trade
with I'm telling you you got to be smart
man he's like nope Ray tells me you're
gonna win this one with your mind he
went there and did his thing man yeah he
did yeah and Longo can't walk anymore
but he can sure coach can he man can he
cook that whole team man yeah with marab
you got Sterling there the whole Squad
man's just doing the damn thing so shout
out to them
yeah I think there's a lot of different
ways you can tap into an athlete's mind
and it's nice for me to see some of
these coaches who you know because Ray
it's sometimes it's just about the
mental you know and just having him sort
of there and uh whatever you sort of
need from him you get from him and uh
you know he's not holding myths as much
as he used to that's why for the podcast
anything that he can do to make money
when he's not you know giving of his
body is a really good thing for him I
mean he's doing the merch too you guys
launched his merch and stuff like that
so yep his stuff's the best-selling
stuff you know he's probably put his
name on the [__] show that makes
sense that makes sense well fellas I
know you're busy you got to do your
podcast now
yes yeah we're gonna tape our show in
about three minutes and uh off we go
yeah well I appreciate you guys you know
I love the [__] out of both you
gentlemen so hey man Anna you start
looking at property in North Carolina
hit your boy up dude we'll get a
two-family home together and uh all I
ask is that you'd come on our podcast
and give us like 25 minutes in the next
couple weeks whatever you want man as
long as you can deal with fish and your
wife's cool with it off
good love it all right fellas thanks for
the time man talk soon
later fellas there you have it Kenny
Florian John attic before we jump into
current events
it was the last read for you guys all
right we're talking about on it on
it.com if you missed their Semi-Annual
Sale you're probably pretty sad don't be
too sad because you can still try Alpha
Brain save 10 off we're talking about
Alpha Brain the best neutral book on the
planet they sell over a million bottles
I used Alpha Brain Black Label it's the
highly concentrated Alpha Brain but if
you're if you're not a vet like me with
the Alpha Brain nootropics try just a
regular Alpha Brain you have no this
wrist
no no rest here because they get your
money back guaranteed you don't have to
return the product keep the product they
return your money if you don't
absolutely love Alpha Brain all right
it's best nootropic you use alphabet
however you want they have the regular
Alpha Brain right or they have the Alpha
Brain Black they got Alpha Brain instant
they have the shots I love them all but
Alpha Brain Black I swear by right now
remember with nootropics you can
remember names better places addresses
phone numbers helps you with complex
tasks think more clearly under stress
react more quickly who can't use that so
if you've always want to try a nootropic
try Alpha Brain they've sold over a
million bottles for God's sakes I like
the black label it's super super
effective all right also Anna as you
guys well know they offer fitness
equipment like kettlebell steel Club
Macy's sandbags yoga mats you need
better nutrition trying to get your diet
right for the thick Boy Summer it's not
a UFC summer because UFC is a little
light right it's a thick boy summer so
if you need to get that body right and
you get that body popping like Almeda in
the main event you they have MCT oil
protein how does protein bars Warrior
bars we got it all creatine fish oil
Alpha Brain all right you can save 10
off when you go to onit.com shop you
receive 10 off all Alpha Brain products
all workout gear Fitness Gear streaming
Fitness we got you covered don't be sad
you missed the Semi-Annual Sale you
still save 10 off go to audit.com right
now receive 10 off now let's get to the
program
they have it two of the best and
brightest man I absolutely love those
guys I think we need to move to North
Carolina fellas sounds good you want to
move to North Carolina
I've spent enough time there I've only
done shows in Charlotte but I didn't get
to really see the city if you move
somewhere new you don't want to move
into like the downtown wherever any
major city you don't want to be downtown
we'll be right outside
that's where you want to be where it's
safe it's nice you drive in the city do
your work and get out daily temperature
around 88. I remember going there once
and it was freaking hot
but beautiful highest average daily temp
is 89. your little humidity they don't
get really snow there do they
don't think they get snow there
oh can't do snow
does North Carolina
it's North Carolina seen regular based
in the mountains not worried about that
they get five inches of snow per winter
season so no that means no I know I've
been there where it gets chilly but as
far as
I think Muggsy bugs live there so that's
another reason
all right chin let's jump right into it
I think me Kenny and uh and it covered
most of the Charlotte card everything
UFC related little pfl Francis news so
let's just jump in What do you got for
me buddy here's a quick one so there's
also a uh Bellator over the weekend and
Fabian Edwards who's uh
one of the best
So Daniel I said this about Johnny
Walker after the win he said he didn't
really wow anyone didn't Charlotte and
then this is exactly what he said here
that didn't sound
that good
working in really wow and this is Dana
White speaking Walker didn't really wow
anybody tonight but he won uh he was put
on the co-main event to kind of shot
tonight he got a w so I guess that's
good so I guess that's good that's a
bummer because he he outclassed Anthony
you know Smith who's an absolute monster
top five perennial top five Caesar said
than done you know to Dana White's point
there he could have got him out of there
he could he could have the flag knee
wobbled him that was late
um when Anthony Smith was just down kind
of grabbing you know at the legs there
it looked like Anthony wanted out but
you know I think Johnny Walker is
showing maturity there didn't want to
risk anything or he got the W yeah
you're not gonna you're not gonna
impress the UFC brass when you play it
safe but he'll get a big name next
okay so this the audio doesn't work on
this because I think it's copywritten so
we're not gonna play it anyways but
there's a guy from the the post or no
I'm sorry this is a press conference for
Nate Diaz Jake Paul and one of the guys
that works for Jay Paul at better he
called out Nate Diaz's brother Nick in a
really douchebag way the whole but the
usually the uh the event especially when
you know Logan Paul I'm sorry Jake Paul
Logan to that point too but Jake Paul
they they
put on the whole press conference
they're the whole production yeah
usually it's great the press conference
is crashed this one was awkward Nate
seemed like you didn't really want to be
there Jake didn't know how to handle
Nate really it was awkward and then you
get the cherry on top of a complete [__]
show you have this just total
tool get on the mic and he goes it's
Derek from better media here my question
is for Nate Nate I'm actually a boxer
myself you're not and I've been trying
to get into this undercard then he said
I'm wondering if you think I could fight
your brother Nick if he's anything like
you I think I could beat his [__] ass
yeah uh brother what are you gonna just
know this is Nate brother what are you
just gonna walk around the street to
some [__] you know all my homeboys see
right now that was stupid hey Derek
better me to a stupid ass mother trucker
what the truck you need your ass Whip
and then he got fired because apparently
that's because Jake was like he works
for me I'm gonna fire him
and then the kid had he got so much
backlash yeah the Diaz family bro
backlashes
it comes in like a landslide this kid
had no idea what he's doing I don't
I don't understand I mean I guess it's
the MMA journalist douche reacting in a
nutshell right like these guys think
they can talk to Nick like this yeah
there's gonna be repercussions and it's
also you know he's not a journalist it's
too easy to be a label a journalist
these days but
for this kid too I just I don't know
what the motive was there oh you think
Nate's gonna or Nick's gonna fight you
on the undercard you have no fight it
the whole thing just so stupid so cringy
it's and it couldn't be worse for Jake
Paul you won't be taken serious and this
guy works for your business he's part of
this is the biggest story out of the
press conference it's not good yeah it's
pretty lame so he but I would like to
apologize for the question I asked at
the Jake Paul Nate Diaz press conference
I would especially like to apologize to
my boss Jake Paul and definitely want to
apologize to Nate Diaz Nate please don't
hurt me but if you do I definitely
deserve it I haven't said all this Nick
Diaz the contract has been sent and then
he'd call that Drake too
everything's cringe about this
who's just a complete tool yeah kids
probably not giving me the business too
much longer
if even was in the business who knows
who knows
um so this oh this was bad yeah rolly
Romero versus Ismail barosso and then
everyone agrees that the stoppage was
way too early it just shows you how
corrupt box it is
they didn't want this Old vat beating
the young kid and he was about to do it
and then Tony week stops the fight
Clarissa Shields what'd she say uh boxes
took an L tonight that [__] was pathetic
and barosso's 8 40. I don't know I don't
care what y'all say good night y'all
done ruin the
G quote the greatest woman of all time
and that's Ryan Garcia
wow that was dirty way too early yeah
super super Shady people this one's
funny from combosa even if he's 63.
because he he looks really old yeah it's
a trip he does yeah yeah boxing's so
crap man
um so Rampage Jackson's over at the UFL
his son won his UFL debut well down in
Memphis Tennessee UFL two went down uh
man and they hit 200 000 views on Rumble
which is insane for a new Fight League
on Rumble especially
um you guys know Frank man Rampage
they're both super heavily involved in
UFL
um yeah so I think it was cool for
Rampage to have his son fight in his
hometown you know TKO went to Roger got
it done he opened the card super
impressive Tico and I think his dazzling
turned pronoun yep what do you want he
want he said he had to have 10 amateur
fights but after passing This Test
season let him turn pro uh the whole
card was good I watched all of it
um you know the people from the UK South
America you look good
he looked really good yes sir
um Okay so
as soon as Matt Brown won I guess he
tied for most Kos with Derek Lewis and
then Conor McGregor tweeted about it or
said something about it
Matt Brown up 42 years of age now holds
the joint highest kill inside the UFC
with 13 kills him and the Beast Dirk
Lewis are tied I hold eight kills that's
five short inside the UFC currently at
34 years of age I'm getting this record
and then Matt Brown
he goes I'll fight you for it yep that's
hilarious
I'd watch that fight all day
uh we talked about this already but yeah
so tomorrow so May 16th yeah I assume I
can't believe Kennedy didn't give us
Kenny you know dude yeah Kenny knows how
dare you but uh
yeah May 16th I I mean I don't think
that it's gonna be pfl where else is he
gonna go yeah unless he does some sort
of like
here's another quick one uh Henry
sujudo's coach who's kind of odd you
know Eric glasses yeah he was on your
Juana show is Ariel helwani show and he
said that UFC 288 had 700 000
pay-per-view buys but no one ever you
know there's no Al Joe said I think I
think they did 225 at the moment gets a
pay-per-view cut so he would know yeah
I was told yesterday this is Alger ago I
was told yesterday we'd be lucky to
break 250 pay-per-view buys and you're
going to air going on air to lie that
you know for certainly made 700 000 are
you on the on the bottle this afternoon
bro stop the cap for the old heads out
there cat means lying I don't know why
do you guys you know the definition of
cap yeah I mean it means lying but I
don't know why I'm saying why I have no
idea me neither we're old yeah
yeah there's no way that that fight did
700 bucks I don't but why put that out
there that's just him trying to get
traction for his guy you know be like
look he's actually a drawn it's like no
I mean I'm sure the actual pay-per-view
numbers will eventually come out so it's
gonna look weird yeah maybe uh your boy
Sean O'Malley remember when he first
thought that would have won well we had
remember we did a one-on-one with sugar
Shawn last week and I said you were
sitting cage side you scored it for
sahuto I said obviously that's gonna be
biased because everybody knows watching
K side this is why the judges scoring is
ridiculous it's not it's hard to
critique a fight it's hard to judge it
correctly he goes yeah you're right I
need to watch it here we go re-watch any
versus aljo 4-1 Al Joe that's completely
different crazy how much different the
fight looked from being there live
compared to TV
so boy were you off yeah dude I gotta
watch it again
uh you might be right I mean just me
Dominic Cruz sugar Sean think Al Joe I
know you might be right dude we're
sipping like oh that's that's I never
put too much weight into when we
critique the fights off of that uh also
Sean O'Malley so Mother's Day just
happened on his YouTube channel he gave
away a hundred thousand dollars to his
wife uh I believe his wife and his mom
so 50k each oh 50k Dana White bonus he's
got a lot of money dude
so that was pretty dope yeah that's cool
trying to outshine all the
Suns out there God 50k man give my wife
some sneakers well you buy her cars and
stuff so well yeah
um so I I didn't want to bring this up
for candy to answer but apparently nine
fighters from pfl are suspended and they
won't say exactly what it is but most
likely it's and there's more drugs yeah
yeah there's more yeah yeah there's a
lot more there too and it was over like
a period of time like it wasn't like all
in one fight card it's over a period of
time apparently there's a lot more to
this story as well gotcha
anybody who thinks on steroids and pfl
they're on steroids yeah it's like pfl
go ahead yeah let them do their thing
yeah it's like slap Fight League that's
the funniest one do Coke and slap
uh this is obviously this is going to
come but uh so Robbie Lawler announced
that he's going to retire after his next
fight yeah but he's not in the main card
is he
was an undercard the like the last
prelim or something I think so
I don't know but that's against legal
price loliverse Nico will headline the
prelims damn
all this this guy's done how much with
UFC's on the prelims you son of a [__]
I get it though him and Nico price on
the the last prelim that I don't no no
dude do you have somebody else do it he
deserves to be on the main cards you
definitely deserve ridiculous
it's Robbie Lawley son of a [__] how's
he not on the main card for his last
fight all he's done for the UFC
disrespectful
um did you read this headline already
Jon Jones
for his pay-per-view it grossed with
more than the UFC has in the past 12
months so just out of the year I always
told you guys The Narrative that Jon
Jones is in a big pay-per-view start
that was created by the UFC back in the
day they pushed that narrative push that
in there it's just not true you look at
his numbers it's not true in any facet
massive pay-per-view star
probably the biggest they have you look
at over his long career
yep
um revenue of three
353.3 million for the quarter which is
up to which is up 56.6 million do you
just look at his numbers of all the
major papers these headlines the numbers
are solid now are they Ronda Rousey
Conor McGregor no but over just the
average he's a pay-per-view star man
he's a Grace of all time the UFC pushed
that native which is so weird because
that's your product man it doesn't make
sense he represents you guys
so this weekend
is
Kenzie Dern versus Angela Hill love
McKenzie Hill at the Apex too yeah
here's the card
my boy Edmund shelbazian's fight is the
co-main event Anthony Hernandez that's a
great fight
it's a tough card Miss very tough very
tough
Chase Hoover back in action
it's a tough [__] car so tough I
tried hyping you guys up I'm sorry
we're looking at you know because we're
looking for companions or to break down
stuff
The Summer's not fun
usually they pack this summer it's tough
man someone put out this question would
you rather the UFC do less cards so we
get more big name fights like stack
cards or just keep doing what they're
doing so you have a fight every week
I would rather have less cards more
stacked lineups it definitely felt a lot
bigger back in the days yeah
because now you're on the boxer model
you know which clearly that hasn't
worked out for them
yeah and everything's up in the air
yeah
uh Devin Haney's your good one that's
coming up May 20th
yeah there's not a lot to be excited
about we're just waiting man
yeah Summer's light
it is not a UFC summer it's a thick Boy
Summer not a UFC summer I know hopefully
we get news though with Francis yeah and
uh Jon Jones the July card stacked the
paper in July stacked
June's tough yeah
yeah is that it that's pretty much it
all right dude those are terrible
all right kids hope you all enjoyed the
show hope you enjoyed the brilliant John
attic Kenny flooring Pasadena see this
Friday at the Ice House shop and Friends
8 P.M show and then June 2nd to the 4th
the tour officially picks back up in The
Comedy Store in La Jolla right outside
San Diego that's a Friday Saturday
Sunday show and then starting June 15th
I'm jumping over to the UK I'm in
Belfast Glasgow Manchester London
Cardiff and Dublin get your tickets at
thickboy.com
all right kids that's it be nice each
other love you go nuggets see you next
week